searching for airaid shelters
theoretically they're dotted throughout
the eastern ukrainian city of kharkiv a
website identifies the basements of
buildings designated by the government
as suitable bunkers if the city comes
under attack
if it does happen everyone is directed
to these shelters there are said to be
four thousand three hundred of them but
yulia smayner has only been able to find
100 so far and of them 94 were
uninhabitable or more commonly locked
julia works her way through the site
often asking locals for assistance in
finding the shelter
yes
um
not a single person we met had a good
word to say for them
the tension's rising here the lack of
preparedness is becoming a big issue for
the government
so it seems this shelter
appears at least that this shelter is
actually up to its knees in water the
ladies saying that um
we're just getting directions they start
there obviously it's quite a big issue
they're pretty angry about this because
the one place that they know they would
at least be able to protect themselves
from the russian
missiles is
you know impossible they're either
locked or in this case it's full of
water
downstairs is genuinely awful the stench
of human waste is overpowering
it is impossible to imagine anyone
taking refuge here
julia will report her latest findings to
the authorities
like many she's got used to the threats
coming from russia and like many she
believes one day russia will invade
do you think the russians will invade i
think
today now
and tomorrow now but
in the in future maybe
maybe in future because
they want us
to
break
yeah
our country yes and
make it the uh
two times a week every week eleanor
cover and her daughter daria meet in
their kitchen running through safety
protocols they've developed if car keefe
is attacked where they will hide and
where they will try to escape
they have an emergency escape bag with
some medicines and passports permanently
ready to go
elena escaped the separatist city of
luhansk taken over in 2014
she's praying it doesn't happen again
um
you do all this preparation with your
mum are you very scared about what's
coming are your friends very scared
um
the dire warnings about an invasion and
huge casualties here there's no
discernible sense of panic people are
worried of course but nothing's really
changed
on wednesday the country's been called
to celebrate its existence
it's the same day that some have said
russia will invade though they don't
seem to believe it here mr ramsey sky
news car keefe